und als gäbe es nicht genügend steuern
basteln einige umweltexperten jetzt
schon an der neuen steuer und das ist es
was zu sagen kein witz sie basteln an
einer steuer für kühe genauer gesagt
nach vorsteuer für für
grüne wiesen kleine kälber grasende kühe
sieht gar nicht nach umwelt bedrohung
aus doch kein anderes nutztier verdaut
so klimaschädlich wie die kuh so heißt
es und ihr pupsen könnte ganz schön
teuer werden über den pansen generiert
das nutztier mit haben das ist die
klimaschädliche variante von co2 alle
drei minuten rutscht der kuh einer raus
[Musik]
bis zu 100 gramm methan kann eine
einzelne kuh im jahr ausblasen
deshalb liebäugelt der chef des
umweltbundesamtes dirk messner mit einer
co2 steuer für kühe weil die halt so
viel putzen das wäre sie dann die
vorsteuer der verbandschef
familienbetriebe land und forst ev max
freiherr von elverfeldt lässt daraufhin
erstmal ganz schön dampf ab wer das
putzen und rülpsen von kühen mit einer
klimasteuer belegen will der besteuert
das leben selbst und wo soll dieser
klimawandel beenden was kommt dann als
nächstes auf den tisch eine geruchs
steuer für volle babywindeln oder eine
allgemeine steuer pflicht für
verbrauchte atemluft zumal es für
blähungen von küren ja auch noch andere
lösungen gibt einschicken rucksack zum
beispiel
so machen dass die argentinischen bauern
vor auch das umweltbundesamt findet die
idee von seinem chef nicht so durfte um
die landwirtschaft klima und
umweltfreundlicher zu gestalten braucht
es einen mix aus verschiedenen maßnahmen
eine co2 abgabe auf linda empfiehlt das
umweltbundesamt jedoch gegenwärtig nicht
immerhin sind auch nur drei prozent der
gesamtdeutschen methan emissionen auf
die kuh selber zurückzuführen der
verkehr kommt auf knapp 20 prozent also
eine kuh ist kein auto am ende
vielleicht also doch nur alles heiße
luft
darüber sprechen wir jetzt verbunden
sind wir mit max von elverfeldt
vorsitzender der familienbetriebe land
und forst schön dass sie hier bei uns
sind ja wenn wir jetzt er die kuh bzw
den furz von der kuh besteuern so was
für das was ging ihnen durch den kopf
als sie geht von diesem vorschlag gehört
haben ja also völliger irrsinn was dort
kotierte zeigen einfach wie ideologisch
die klimapolitik und wenig
praxistauglich thema politik diskutiert
wird jetzt an der ku steuer ist aber
sehr plastisch gezeigt worden wo kommen
wir da hin dann fangen wir irgendwann
anders wir den puls unserer kinder
bestehen müssen das zeigt einfach wie
wenig ebens tauglich solche gedanken
sind ich bin hier extra eine kuhweide
haben als ich bin erfahren haben was wir
wollten und so gemobbt werden sie gleich
mal abgehauen
das glaube ich ihnen alles andere
allerdings schon das umweltbundesamt hat
ja die kuh dann erst mal so ein bisschen
doch vom eis geholt und hat gesagt akkus
steuer vielleicht doch nicht aber wie
wäre es denn wenn wir alle weniger kühe
hätten also haben sie haben wir alle in
deutschland so viele kühe
also man muss immer gucken wir ob man
das ganze auf zieht natürlich
grundsätzlich stimmt natürlich sie haben
sie einen bericht gehe auch gesagt klar
die mit ihren natürlichen getan von co2
aber die frage wie regeln wäre das das
kann ja nicht dadurch gehen indem wir
hier die produktion einschränken das
treffen zum einen die arbeitsplätze
fielen
sie müssen dann teurer machen das hat
die entsprechende auswirkung daneben an
der kasse im supermarkt der käse butter
und milch teurer werden wir haben gerade
erfahren in england banken sie jetzt
damit an weil der käse preise so stark
gestiegen ist da dort schon den
diebstahl sicher und daran hängt weil
sie sorgen haben dass käse geklaut wird
also die gefahr dass dort eben die
preise gewaltig steigen
zeigt ein kunde wie er sie nicht das ist
aber grundsätzlich stimmt das natürlich
und die frage ist wie man das thema eben
angeht und wir können wir eben nicht
über die produktion seite kommen wir
müssen bei den nachfrage bei den
konsumenten anfragen dort müssen der
sensibilisierung hinbringt tatsächlich
einfach weniger fleischprodukte
milchprodukte zu konsumieren dann wird
auch weniger produziert und erzeugt und
dann kommen wir auch zu ziel aber man
muss eben aufpassen wo man dass die
adaption an der nächste punkt ist ja
auch das werler verlagerungseffekten
befürchten müssen aktuell ist es so dass
wir in deutschland hat sich eine kleine
überproduktion haben wir 110 111 prozent
der milch wer in deutschland brauchen
werden auch in deutschland produziert
also wir können elf exportieren wenn wir
jetzt einfach sagen wir reduzieren ich
sag mal was um 20 prozent und der konsum
geht nicht gleichzeitig runter dann
müssen wir milch importieren aus anderen
ländern und pupsen gar die kühe und noch
nichts gewonnen ja das stimmt dann ist
nur unsere weste sozusagen ein bisschen
bisschen weißer hierher deutschland aber
mich interessiert wir gucken ja überall
nach emissionseinsparungen das
emissionsfreie auto die emissionsfreie
heizung gibt sie auch die emissionsarme
kuh
gibt es natürlich am ende nicht weil
sich natürlich einfach methan und co2
aus buchs ist nun mal zum geschäft und
umwelt ab natürlich recht also da gibt
es keine art von rudi vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger und dann ein bisschen
emissions-
günstiger ist bisschen fans gefragt ist
natürlich deshalb bin ich auch mit ihm
hier auf die weide gegangen und sie
haben das ja auch in ihrer anmoderation
gezeigt wie kühe auf der weide das sind
sogar wahre klimaschützer weil die ja
das gras auf den grünflächen fressen und
gleichzeitig ihre verdauung auf der
wiese lassen und das fördert die co2 im
humus im boden und bin dadurch co2
und dort wird mehr gebunden als die cdu
denn beim pupsen wieder raus lässt
insofern ist die weidehaltung auf jeden
fall eine co2 positive sie halten also
kommen kuh und klima ja doch irgendwie
zusammen und sie können sogar ableiten
es gibt ja einen verdauungs mechanismen
der kühe sogar auch noch positiv
weil vielen herzlichen dank für das
gespräch mit einer für ihre zeit
[Musik]